Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Ariana Bleau Lugo
Ciao a tutti, sono emozionatissima!
Volevo suggerire al ragazzo di prima
la soluzione per il sudore:
la maglietta nera.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Negli ultimi sette mesi
ho vissuto per strada,
completamente senza soldi,
ho dormito ogni notte
sotto un tetto diverso,
e già tanto se era un tetto.
Questi sono i posti dove ho dormito.
Fino a 22 giorni fa ho vissuto
completamente senza soldi
e queste erano le mie scarpe.
Queste scarpe le ho comprate a Londra
l'anno scorso per essere un angelo.
Che cosa vuol dire essere un angelo?
Un angelo è una massaggiatrice
di teste
di giocatori di poker ai tornei di poker.
Queste scarpe hanno solcato tutti
i casinò più prestigiosi d'Inghilterra.
Stavo in piedi anche per 12 ore al giorno
per massaggiare i giocatori,
quindi un paio di scarpe comode
erano essenziali.
Sulla loro suola c'è scritto "Go Walk":
vai a camminare.
Ogni mattina le mettevo
per andare a lavorare
e questa frase mi rimbombava
nella testa: vai a camminare!
Un giorno stavo massaggiando
un giocatore particolarmente nervoso
e cominciai a guardarmi intorno:
Che ora era? Che giorno era?
Che cosa ci stavo facendo li?
Mi guardai intorno,
non trovai nemmeno un orologio.
I casinò sono dei posti senza tempo,
proprio per far perdere la cognizione
del tempo ai giocatori.
Lo stesso stava succedendo
con la mia vita.
Mi ero completamente persa,
non sapevo più nemmeno perché ero lì.
Il giocatore che stavo massaggiando
era particolarmente nervoso,
mi stava procurando la nausea.
Mi sentivo stufa di vivere
in quel limbo senza tempo
ed esplosi e dissi:
"Sorry sir, I quit!
I need to go for a walk!"
Mi dispiace, mi licenzio,
devo andare a fare una passeggiata!
E così feci! Mi licenziai!
Uscii dal casino a Marble Arch
e camminai fino a casa a Whitechapel,
solo una manciata di chilometri
a Londra nella notte,
una notte qualsiasi per tutti,
ma non per me.
La prima frase che mi venne in mente
fu quella di Jep Gambardella
ne "La grande bellezza", che dice:
"A 65 anni non ho più tempo per fare
quello che non mi piace fare!"
Bene! Perché dovevo aspettarne altri 30
per giungere alla stessa conclusione?
Sapevo esattamente cosa
non mi piaceva fare,
ma mi ero completamente
dimenticata i miei sogni!
Incominciai a ripercorrere la mia vita.
Fin da piccola sono stato
una bambina sempre distratta,
con la testa tra le nuvole,
sempre a guardare fuori dalla finestra,
sempre a consegnare per ultima
i compiti in classe.
E la mia maestra mi diceva:
"Sveglia, Darinka, sveglia!
Il tempo è denaro,
il tempo è denaro!"
Una frase orribile che mi ha
tormentato per tutta la vita,
facendomi pensare
che il mio essere lenta
fosse un grandissimo difetto
e che veramente
stessi perdendo soldi nell'esserlo.
Ultimamente però ho incominciato
a leggerla diversamente:
ora penso che il mio essere lenta
mi porta potenzialmente
ad essere molto ricca.
Poi che altro? Nel 2004 mi sono laureata
in fotografia a Westminster a Londra
e da lì sono partita: ho viaggiato
attraverso molti continenti,
adattandomi ad ogni situazione.
Ho fatto veramente qualsiasi
tipo di lavoro:
dalla barista in bikini
nelle miniere australiane,
all’insegnante d’inglese nel Laos.
Veramente di tutto.
Mi stavo adattando
alle esigenze del mondo,
però forse, se avessi fatto
quello che piaceva fare a me,
il mondo, per una volta,
si sarebbe adattato a me!
E che cosa mi piace fare?
Finalmente avevo ritrovato
i miei sogni: viaggiare, scrivere,
fotografare e sognare,
senza fretta, con calma.
Finalmente l'idea era chiara
nella mia testa:
sarei ritornata in Italia
e me la sarei fatta tutta a piedi,
raccogliendo sogni:
cercando di stimolare
nella gente che avrei incontrato
quello che era successo a me
quella notte magica.
Un po' come fa Atreyu
ne "La storia infinita":
cercare di sconfiggere il Nulla
stimolando la fantasia della gente!
Perché sognare
è una sottile forma di ribellione
e mettere in pratica i propri sogni
vera e propria rivoluzione.
Quindi presi un volo per Malpensa.
Arrivai a casa, i miei genitori
mi vennero a prendere all'aeroporto,
preoccupati: "Cosa ci fai in Italia
dopo 15 anni che non ti vediamo!?"
Gli dissi che stavo per partire
per Palermo per tornare a casa a piedi!
"Ah... domani piove..."
Mi assecondarono come si fa coi pazzi.
In effetti io mi sentivo
completamente folle.
Non ero molto convinta.
Non avevo messo da parte una lira!
Come si fa [a viaggiare senza soldi]?
Concettualmente era perfetto:
viaggio senza soldi e ti dimostro
che posso realizzare i miei sogni
anche senza denaro.
Ma a piedi?
Io a piedi non ero neanche mai andata
al supermercato!
Google e trovo chi l'ha fatto prima di me.
Mi risponde ad un tale: Riccardo
Carnovalini, intrepido camminatore
che ha camminato ovunque in Italia,
estasiato dalla mia follia.
Finalmente ci incontriamo in un bar
e per tre ore e mezza
lo martello di domande:
"Riccardo, come faccio?
Che scarpe mi servono?
Che zaino mi porto?
Come faccio per la pioggia?
E per l'acqua?
Ma, secondo te, è fattibile!?
Mi ha dato una botta di carica:
"Certo che ce la puoi fare, vai!
Grande! OK!" Da lì, la svolta!
Tornata a casa sembra che sappia
di cosa sto parlando!
Prenoto il mio volo per Palermo.
C'è solo un'ultima cosa che mi blocca:
ho una paura folle!
Paura di fallire, paura dell'ignoto,
paura che non troverò
da dormire né da mangiare.
Paura della paura, paura di tutto!
Arrivo a Palermo e comincio
a camminare ed è come se quella paura
fosse stato un enorme muro di vetro
e attraversandolo si è infranto
in mille piccoli pezzi
che ora posso prendere
e guardare uno a uno.
Ora conosco le mie paure!
Ho paura delle sopraelevate
perché soffro di vertigini.
Ho paura di camminare nelle gallerie.
Ho paura dei pastori maremmani
e ho paura di chi si ferma
per offrirmi passaggi
in modo molto insistente.
Però in questi mesi mi sono
inventata dei piccoli stratagemmi
per risolvere queste paure.
Per esempio, a chi si ferma
per offrirmi un passaggio
dico che sto facendo un documentario
e che c’è una troupe televisiva
che mi sta seguendo.
Al che se la squagliano velocemente.
Come se queste paure fossero state
dei pezzi di vetro
lasciati sul bagnasciuga e dopo mesi
sono stati levigati, ora non sono più
tanto taglienti come all'inizio.
Ora io, in 12 minuti, sinceramente,
non ce la faccio a raccontarvi
che cosa mi è successo
negli ultimi mesi,
ma vi posso dire
che mi sono divertita un casino
e ho un segreto, anzi due.
Il primo è il sorriso!
Un'arma potentissima che abbiamo tutti
e che mi ha aperto tutte le porte:
sono riuscita a dormire
quasi sempre sotto un tetto
e a mangiare quasi tutti i giorni.
Sono riuscita ad attraversare
lo stretto di Messina
e anche entrare nella maggior parte
dei musei che volevo.
Poi c'è un'altra arma che abbiamo:
il potere dell’ascolto.
In una società dove ormai buttiamo
fuori parole senza neanche
preoccuparci più dei contenuti,
siamo rimasti veramente in pochi
a tendere le orecchie per ascoltare
e in questo viaggio
sto cercando di imparare a farlo.
Prima ho ascoltato il consiglio
delle mie scarpe,
poi quello del mio cuore
e poi i moltissimi sogni di tutti
gli Italiani che ho incontrato
in questo viaggio, che mi ha permesso
di tornare a casa con un bagaglio
di valore inestimabile!
E ve lo voglio fare vedere!
Questi sono i sogni di tutti!
Ne ho uno in particolare che mi piace,
il sogno di una bambina: Annachiara,
di 8 anni, che mi aveva scambiato
per un mix tra Babbo Natale
e il genio della lampada.
Annachiara mi ha consegnato
una vera e propria lista:
1. avere un chihuahua;
2. avere un Samsung;
3. un fidanzato;
4. volare;
Interessante: fidanzato, poi volare!
5. essere incinta senza mal di pancia;
(Risate)
6. avere denti belli senza apparecchio e
7. che non mi crescano i peli
sotto le ascelle e nella patatina.
(Applausi)
Il giorno dopo Annachiara
si è svegliata alle sei
perché voleva darmi il suo ultimo sogno:
ci ha pensato tutta la notte
per portarmi questo:
"Vorrei che tutti i bambini del mondo
siano fortunati come me
e che non soffrano mai!"
(Applausi)
OK, il mio progetto non è rivoluzionario,
non ho cambiato il mondo
però ho cambiato il mio mondo!
Il mio destino era nelle mie scarpe
e non me ne ero neanche accorta!
Ora voglio lasciarvi con una domanda:
dov'è il vostro destino?
Qual è il vostro sogno?
Vi giuro che anche solo spendere
cinque minuti a pensare a questo
potrebbe sorprendentemente
cambiarvi la vita!
Grazie.
(Applausi)